- I know. I know.
I am so honored you're here.
I'm such a big fan of your work.
I was a fan of you before Babylon.
We're going to get to it.
- First of all likewise.
You are an icon.
You're iconic, Kelly.
- [Kelly] Oh, you're very nice but-
(crowd cheering)
Y'all are going to be blown
the hell away with this movie.
- [Margot] Oh yeah.
- The movie, your character,
I'm going to get to it.
- If you thought you
just had New Year's Eve,
it's like you're going to
relive that vibe all over again.
- It's like New Year's Eve on LSD
but it's also like-
Okay, I'm going to get to it.
I want to start with you first
because I do want to
talk about your project
but you're more important.
So what are you going to do this year?
I don't like making resolutions
because I always fail at them.
So we're doing like, what are
you going to do better at?
What are you doing for yourself this year?
- I always make a ridiculous
list of resolutions,
most of which are totally unobtainable,
and then it gets to, yeah, like December
and I'm like, oh, didn't do any of that.
But some are achievable.
Like one year I was like,
I want to learn to make jam
and I was able to accomplish that.
- I made jam.
- [Margot] I made jam.
- Was it good, jam?
- It was pretty good.
To be honest, I'd still buy
it instead of making it,
but anyway.
- [Kelly] It's a process.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah, I did it on a really hot day too,
which I don't recommend.
Do it in winter.
Anyways, this year was
on my list last year.
I didn't get around to it,
but I really want to learn the banjo.
(banjo playing)
- Oh.
- [Margot] Oh, my gosh.
I'm telling you, literally my band,
they all play like everything,
specifically Jocko as well.
- [Jocko] I am ready.
- You play banjo as well?
You're incredible.
(banjo music)
Oh my gosh.
- [Jocko] When do we start?
- Oh, honestly, tomorrow.
Anytime please.
I'm not kidding.
I've been looking for a banjo teacher.
- We heard!
We heard you were looking
for a banjo teacher.
- [Jocko] I got you.
- [Kelly} We're like,
we know a banjo player.
And he's really good.
But why a banjo?
I'm just curious.
- I don't know.
It just seems like a great instrument.
I love the sound of it.
And I also, I know this is silly,
but like I think it'd be
really funny if I was ever
on a camping trip
and I played like the
music from Deliverance
just to freak people out,
like hide in a tree and do it but-
- I think what would freak them out
if he yelled squeal, piggy, squeal.
- [Margot] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well I thought, look,
if they don't get that reference,
then there's a few go-to lines
and hopefully they'll pick up
on what I am doing but yeah.
- Oh, my God. The banjo
is a cool instrument.
- I've been learning French,
but I want to be fluent in French.
That would be cool.
- Oh, I've been learning
Spanish for decades. (laughs)
Unless you practice it every day,
like my brain just doesn't work like that.
It does not sink it.
I can read it, but speaking,
that's the hardest thing.
Do you find?
- Yes, especially like
with French, it's like,
I'm pretty good at reading it,
and then if I'm hearing it,
and then as soon as someone
asks me to speak, I'm like,
(stammers).
- [Kelly] Yeah and then you tense up
and you're like, I've
never heard this language
in my entire life before.
Yup.
- On the flip side, I just work,
my amazing co-star, Diego
Calva, who's in Babylon.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- English is his second language.
Spanish is his first language.
He's from Mexico City.
And somehow have done this
entire journey with him
and still don't know,
like my Spanish has not improved at all.
He, meanwhile, like learnt
his English perfectly,
could improvise entire scenes in English.
I mean he was remarkable.
- It is remarkable how people
can pick it up so quickly.
- [Margot] Yeah.
- I think it's a beautiful thing.
- So many people are
bilingual, trilingual,
and I'm like-
- [Kelly] Yeah, especially in Europe.
- I only speak Australian
English, American.
- I love that you said Australian.
- Yeah. It's different!
- Totally!
- It's a different lingo, you know,
it's a lot to learn.
- [Kelly] I love Australia.
That was my first place whenever,
after I went idol like 20 years ago,
it was the first place I like went.
I had no idea what rugby was.
They had me performing this big
thing there and it was huge.
Just like y'alls Super Bowl, I guess.
And I-
- It wasn't State of Origin, was it?
- I don't know what is it the NRL?
The National Rugby League?
- [Margot] Yeah.
- It was this big thing.
- Oh, you played for
the big, like the thing?
- [Kelly] It was enormous.
I had no idea what I was signing up for.
And, but what I love about Australians
y'all are like Texans.
I'm from Texas.
Everybody's so nice.
Like friendly, like,
sure, come on in!
Like, everybody's just very friendly.
I love Australia.
- I always said, I was like,
if I was born in America
I'd definitely be from like
Texas or I'd be from the South.
Like, that's just like
the vibe of where I'm from
in Australia.
- Well, especially if you
like making jam in the heat,
that's very southern.
- And learning the banjo.
- It's all becoming clear now.
Was it hard to adjust
coming from Australia?
Like to America?
Like, was that weird?
Especially Hollywood?
- It was a bigger, you know,
jump culturally than I was expecting.
More than anything,
I was just amazed to see
how many things I'd seen
in the movies were actually true.
I, you know, so many instances.
I was like, wow,
everyone does drink out
of red cups at a party
and like,
oh there are yellow cabs and
people do yell on the street.
Like it's so like, I was like, oh my God.
It's just like the movies.
- Do you miss being there?
- [Margot] I do, all the time.
- Yeah.
- It's beautiful.
- Yeah, I'm going soon but yeah.
- It's wonderful.
It's just kind of one of the
last wild places to me too.
Like I've literally done shows
out in the middle of nowhere
and I was like, we all were like,
so if the world ends and we're
here, who can build a fire?
Like we were in the middle
of nowhere at some festival
and I-
- Oh yeah.
- [Kelly] Bring your banjo.
- [Margot] Yeah.
- It was like, I didn't know
if we were going to make it.
It was literally,
I'd never been that kind
of place in Australia.
I've been like Melbourne and Sydney
and all the major like cities.
- But yeah, you go somewhere
like Tasmania and it's like-
- [Kelly] Wildly different. Yeah.
- It's wild.
It's like being middle earth
like in Lord of the Rings.
You're like, everything looks different.
- It's kind of interesting though.
It's kind of uncharted territory too,
so it's kind of, it's
beautiful in that sense.
- [Margot] It's so beautiful.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then New Zealand
is also like, you know,
if there was ever a zombie apocalypse,
like just go straight to New Zealand that-
- It's so pretty.
- It's beautiful but small
and like, it's just, again,
they, well, they did shoot
Lord of the Rings there,
so it makes sense.
It's very middle earth
vibes there as well.
- [Kelly] They knew what they were doing.
- Yeah.
- I cannot say this enough.
It's incredible.
You have to see it.
It's incredible. It's insanity.
There's chaos but then
there's like beautiful moments
and it's such a trip.
The whole movie is such a trip
but tell everybody what it's about
because I don't want to
spoiler alert anything.
- No! You set that up beautifully.
Thank you.
I love that you loved it.
- It's so great.
- It's so good.
- [Kelly] It's wild.
- It's like, the second
I read it, I was like,
I have to be a part of this.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- This character's like once
in a lifetime character.
This movie's like a once
in a career opportunity
and you know, I get a real kick
out of when it comes around
to like Halloween time and
seeing like what, you know,
18 year olds are dressing
up for as Halloween.
Like there's a lot of
Harley Quinn's for sure,
but there's like a resurgence
with the younger generation
with Wolf of Wall Street.
We made that 10 years ago.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- For some reason like 18
year olds are dressing up
as Naomi and Jordan and I was like, wow.
- It's because of all the streaming.
All these people are, they don't know.
- They're like, finding it again.
- Yeah.
- And or like Scarface, it's like,
that's a huge Halloween
costume for young people.
And I'm like, that's amazing
that people are going back
and still loving, you know.
So I really care about-
- You're right though.
This is one of those films.
- I think so.
- Yeah.
- Like I want to be a part of films
that people are going
to watch for decades.
- It's thought-provoking.
- Yeah.
- I literally stopped watching it
and I called my manager
my friends and my friends
and I was like, I don't even
know what to say, right.
Like, and we had this
whole conversation about-
Because I also think that
when you see the movie
you'll get something different from it.
Because I know that the
movie is obviously about
going the, you know,
the progression of film
going from silent film-
- To talkies.
- Yes.
- So I know that that's the main theme.
But there's also about how this town
it can be beautiful and
wonderful and so much awe
but like, it can also exploit
its own and eat its own.
And it's like-
- Totally.
- It's all that's there.
- It's kind of like a real,
like, people keep saying like,
oh it's a love,
Damien's writing a love
letter to Hollywood.
And I was like, I think
it's true but it's kinda-
- [Kelly] It's a really
messed up letter. (laughs)
- It's kind of like,
it's almost like it's real true love
because Damian, our
director, is not shying away
from the really ugly parts
of Hollywood as well.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, back then
but also it is majorly a reflection
of where we're at now too.
But you know, it's like wow,
he really loves it
because he can see all the
really gross, awful sides
of it too and the magical sides of it.
And then he's giving you all of that
in this like epic, entertaining,
like, it's a masterpiece.
But it's, I mean, it's so funny as well.
Like it's-
- [Kelly] Your character-
- [Margot] It's laugh out loud hilarious.
- [Kelly] It is funny.
But your character, like, I'm not kidding,
her character is Nelly-
(Margot laughing)
You should win every award
because I feel like you
played every possible role
you could have played in this film
because there's drugs involved.
So there's like, there's
like the mania kind of side,
there's the emotional
side, the dreamer side,
the hurt side, like when the family passed
and like the single tear thing,
the silent with a single tear thing.
It's so funny how they
kept having you repeat it.
I heard that one day or two days
you danced like 14 hours
straight, like two days in a row.
- Oh no, that was like two weeks.
- Like what happened to your body?
- It was like-
- [Kelly] What happened?
How do you do that?
- I don't know.
- Because this is not normal dancing.
Are they talking about
the scene at the party?
- [Margot] Yeah. Yeah.
- Holy!
- Yeah, that was, I
mean, yeah, that was it.
If you see it, you'll be like-
- How did you not break
something in those heels?
Or your, did you do yoga every day?
Like how did you, like I'm to,
this dance scene is incredible.
- I mean that whole sequence was so mad.
We were in that room with all
those people for two weeks,
I reckon and I mean it
was like being at a party
that never ended.
It was like being like a bender
that you couldn't get out of.
But it was so-
- Which is kind of the
point of that party.
That's what it is.
- Which is what you meant to feel like.
Yeah. Yeah.
- And, but yeah, I do this
whole big crazy dance sequence
and it was just like wild and fun.
But like, I had like all the
background artists around me
a lot of them were actual
professional dancers.
A lot of them, you know,
were just, you know,
other background artists.
Some were just friends of
like Damien and Olivia's.
Like, it was just a real
great group of people
and everyone would just
hype each other up.
- Oh my gosh.
The scene that you had to
keep doing over and over
because they were figuring
out how to do sound.
And you had to keep in character
and you had to keep you,
and I mean, would y'all
just lose it on each other?
- Oh my God.
- [Kelly] That is incredible.
- That escalated.
That scene got so out of hand.
It's so funny though.
That was like one when
I read in the script
and I was like crying with laughter
and when you watch it, you'll
be crying with laughter but-
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
- Yeah, it's like, that's
why this movie is so amazing
because you think of the 1920s Hollywood
and I think of like Great Gatsby parties.
- Think of the glamor.
- You know, a champagne coupe
and like the Charleston.
- [Kelly] This is behind the curtain.
- This is like wow.
It's like-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Margot] Mad.
And it was all true.
Like all these stories.
- [Kelly] It even addresses
like racism and like-
- [Margot] Oh yeah.
- [Kelly] I mean just like,
it addresses everything.
- That scene that Jovan does at the end.
I mean it's so, it's gut-wrenching.
- Yeah, you play Sidney.
- Yep. It's play Sidney Palma.
Yeah and Li Li's character is just
like hugely based on Anna May Wong.
- It's so incredible.
So you use a movement coach,
which I've also heard people use.
And they teach you to
be like certain animals.
I've actually heard this before as well
and this must be a thing.
- It's a thing.
- Yes.
- I didn't go to so drama school,
so I don't know
if this is something that
everyone does in drama school
but it's something I discovered after.
It's something I actually started doing
when I was on I, Tonya.
So that was like the first time-
- What was your animal for I, Tonya?
- I was a pit bull.
- [Kelly] A pit bull?
- Yeah, because they're
very misunderstood.
You know, like-
- [Kelly] I like a pit bull.
- At first glance you're kind of like,
oh, should I be scared?
I have a pit bull too,
so I love pit bulls.
- Oh, I like pit bulls.
- I love a pit bull. Yeah.
But yeah, I wanted like
with her ice skates on
I wanted to be heavy on the feet.
I wanted her to feel like,
I wanted the character
to feel like the world
was like just bearing
down on her all the time.
But then on the ice, she's a
mustang, like a wild horse,
like when she's ice skating.
So she's two animals really.
And then, yeah, every
character I've had animals.
- [Kelly] Who is Nelly?
- Nelly, this is going to sound-
- There's a lot of people in there.
- She's, yeah, she's an
octopus and a honey badger.
- Well octopus, yeah, she's always-
(crosstalk)
- About to say that.
- I have honey badgers on my ranch.
Those are mean little-
- Do you really?
- Yes, they are mean.
- They're insane.
- Yeah.
Oh, I just, you're the honey badger.
The scene when you're eating all the stuff
with the rich people.
- Yes, that's the honey badger.
- [Kelly] Yes. Yes.
- And then the the snake fight scene,
that's all honey badger,
like because there are actual videos
of honey badgers fighting snakes.
There's videos of honey badgers,
which aren't huge animals,
fighting like lions.
- [Kelly] But they're mighty
- And they have like really thick skin
and they're just-
- [Kelly] That is Nelly.
- Like, insane.
Yeah. She has very thick skin.
- Yeah.
- Like, and she just fights anything
and anyone at the drop of a hat.
And playful-
- I love this trick.
- [Margot] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- It's helpful because you do
all this research and like,
you know, there's tons of research
and you read all these books
and watch all these films
and get all these facts
about the real life people
at this time and what,
you know, and sometimes
your head gets so clouded with, you know,
statistics and facts and
the history and bla bla bla-
- Simplify just with movement, yeah.
- But if you just revert
back to the animal
then you can just be
really, really instinctual.